i think my favorite potent combination
is
strength and empathy and you
embody both you have grown up
in extraordinary circumstances take
the hollywood extraordinary most
glamorous
academy award-winning everything you
have lived
an extraordinary life you know what
real life is all about
listen for you to say that i feel that
way about you we were raised in maybe
not the most perfect circumstances
right very different i mean you you were
raised right in the middle of all of
this
and i was raised in south africa which
couldn't be further away from this by
you know two parents who had a road
construction company
and i was raised in a country during a
time a time
that was you know filled with a lot of
turmoil apartheid i was raised during
the apartheid era
i was white and of privilege and i
witnessed how my privilege for years
while i was a young child
got me to places that i just didn't
afford to
other people with a different skin color
and it really
it really traumatized me and then of
course i had my own family issues you
know my father was an alcoholic
he was really sick and this was at a
time
when there was no aaa in south africa
nobody
knew you know and that in south african
culture
it's just like what a man does and so i
was raised in a lot of
a lot of things that you know when i
look at my kids now like they're gonna
have their own trauma somehow of course
right
but to have a little bit of calmness in
the home environment
you know that's i think the other reason
why i just i'm not so eager to jump into
a relationship
because i'm so proud of the fact that my
kids live in a home where they feel safe
and they feel like they're never gonna
have to walk on eggshells
and they're never gonna have to come
down and and and worry about how their
day is gonna go because
mom's boyfriend is not you know or i
don't want
any of that because i i was that's how i
was raised and it's a horror it leaves
it leaves marks on you for sure my dad
was an alcoholic too and it was
because of all those things that made us
the parents we are today
the women we are
and i'm so grateful for my wacky
circumstances because they've made me so
not a victim and so demanding
of having goodness around me and being
such a protective lion
and maybe i wouldn't have been like that
had i not seen that
crap i saw growing up yeah right we'll
never know
but i i do i want to say this i love
that about you
i love that you have just made such a
definitive decision
to just go through your life with joy
and happiness and to actively move
towards that and you
do you do that so so beautifully thank
you
and you fight for others you have ctaop
that's the event i came to that's your
organization
that is a fully functioning incredible
manned organization that makes massive
change in the world and in south africa
and in africa in general
the latest cause you have will you talk
about that ctop
was kind of burst out of what i felt was
a necessity for prevention care with
young people
and at the time it was really focused on
hiv and aids in south africa we're
still unfortunately the hardest hit
country in the world we are one percent
of the world's population
but we represent maybe now over 17
percent of the hiv
population so uh when
covid happened we checked in with all of
our organizations that
we support and the one thing that kept
coming back to us
was that covet had changed the world of
domestic violence
because what was saving most of us
staying home
was a death wish for people who were in
abusive
relationships or abusive families
they're locked
in that danger place they can't escape
it
and so domestic violence just
skyrocketed
and so together for her was a platform
for us to just kind of get together and
and to spread that message
so that we can support those grassroots
organizations who are already doing
um such important work but just have
and especially during an epidemic like
this there's just not enough resources
the fact that i'm getting to know you is
like such a highlight of my life because
you are
such a person of depth and soul
and i just have so much admiration for
you and you're just a stone cold
rad brad rod chick i'm just
i'm just you're rad you're rad i feel
that way about you
i want to have women around me who
inspire me every single day and you do
that for me so
thank you i'm really honored that you
came on the show
and when life opens up a little bit i
would be so
thrilled if our kids get to meet at
being such similar ages and we can
reminisce about the
you know the lion in our life steve
warren and laugh
and tell fart jokes and like just
do our thing i would love that thank you
so much drew
thank you for your time